the definition is that the distance to
the focus P s is the same as the
distance to the directrix
I guess it's D for directrix like so
okay
now P to s that's just two points this
is really easy to do you've got the
square root over here on the left hand
side what's underneath the square root X
minus zero squared
very good plus y minus a square so far
so good when you have a look at the
right hand side this is interesting
you've got a point
and then you've got a line your a point
you're on a line so what we would
normally do you'd normally do
perpendicular distance formula and
that's fine however I'm going to teach
you a sneaky little trick here to help
you work out the perpendicular distance
which is very nice and convenient when
you've got things that are all
horizontal vertical at right angles
watch carefully don't have your pen in
your hand here I just want you to watch
this the perpendicular distance from P
to the directrix can you see it can you
visualize if you had to draw it on the
board where that line is clearly it's
gonna be that's a bit wavy that's an
event it's gonna be this vertical line
are you okay with that is it close
enough for you okay this will be that
perpendicular distance this is PD okay
now because it's vertical I can use the
perpendicular distance formula and I
will get an answer but vertical distance
our distances are much easier to
calculate you don't need to appeal to
some big clunky formula because you know
exactly what the coordinates at that
point are going to be it's a vertical
line it's a vertical line so the x
coordinate down here has to be the same
as the x1 up there so it's just X what
about the y coordinate it's gonna be yet
negative a every y coordinate down here
is negative a so no matter where I'm
should PD if it was here or here or here
here it always get a y-coordinate of
minus pay okay now have a look - a means
oops that you've gone down a units just
like we saw here but if the y-coordinate
up here is just Y then that means that
this vertical distance must be Y that's
what the y-coordinate means so what is
PD in total it's y plus a sorry chance y
plus hey cool it's worth pointing out if
you went ahead and turned the directrix
into general form it would be zero x
plus 1 y plus 8 equals zero and if you
found that into the perpendicular
distance formula lo and behold
eventually you would just get this but
that was a nice direct way to think
geometrically about what was going on
and I think we'd all agree much simpler
then appealing to a big messy formula
okay what are we doing this I should
square both sides to get rid of that
square root while I'm at it I'll
simplify I might as well expand these
guys so y minus l squared
that'll be y squared minus 2a y plus a
squared good right hand side when you
square that you're going to get Y
squared plus 2a y plus a squared again
and as we've observed so many times in
the last few topics things all magically
come out in the wash you're going to Y
squared on both sides and then you also
have an a squared on both sides okay so
now we can see that if I gather what's
left behind try and get it into a nice
neat form I go next square on the left
hand side and I get how many Y's on the
right hand side for a of them put a big
box around that because this is the
locus form of a parabola you've seen
general form you've seen fact
which gives you the roots you've seen
vertex form which gives you well where's
the vertex and this is locus form
because what it's got built into it this
a is that geometric definition from
where this came from
right so normally we don't care about a
because we just wanna know where the
roots are where do we draw this thing
but under this scheme we do care about a
it's the thing that makes it this
parabola what it is okay what would
happen if I made a smaller or bigger hmm
for instance you don't have to write
this but if you considered say x squared
equals 4y x squared equals 4y what would
a be in this case it's 1 because it's 4
times 1 times y so therefore you would
know that the focus is going to be at 0
comma 1 and the directrix would be y
equals negative 1 if on the other hand I
gave you this then you would conclude by
look at that that a is equal to 4 so you
would say the focus is here the vertex
sorry the directrix is down here
according to your new focal length does
that make sense
ok question
if we wanted the standard stock stared
and parabola y equals x squared then to
get just a Y a would have to be a
quarter so its focus would be zero a
quarter and its directrix would be y
equals negative quarter okay